aí acontece não trazendo os pais a não
emitir a conhece algum de vocês aqui a
infância
o capixaba nascido e criado na ilha
ah e eu cozinho hospital mente evento
uma comunidade 100 mil pessoas no
momento mas não vou contar essa história
de como construir o hospital com minha
própria história e começar com uma foto
à
eu sou descendente de indianos meus pais
há 43 anos atrás uma mochila a brasília
na época da ditadura
a gente tinha uma ditadura na época a
meus pais e outros professores da unb
onde eu nasci antes de aumentar
então eu também você mesmo
essa criatura bonita que saiu com três
anos a olhando para o mundo que tanto
entendeu mundo e em nosso site favor
aqui na escola dirce alves lembra
mas enfim uma infância com qualquer
outro e amigos bola de bola
a gente vê algumas coisas diferentes na
infância
ainda não há
eu aprendi a língua dos pais ocorrido em
gaza a mais do que às vezes dá com
exposição e falar olha filho deu muito
bem grande e voto e tem várias pessoas
nesse mundo e várias pessoas nesse mundo
que não têm a oportunidade de você que é
seu dever fazer o melhor com a
oportunidade eo privilégio você tem que
virar um homem para a luta
alguma coisa a gente acabou voltando
para brasília
no meu caso mudando para brasília quando
eu tinha 13 anos que a conta saiu de
vitória
a história é basicamente o que tinham em
causa e meus pais e eu entrei há no
brasil conseguiu uma bolsa na escola
americana em inglês
a pensar um passo na vida onde vou fazer
faculdade apeguei pra faculdade nos
estados unidos foi aceito e
direcioná-las igual aos seus mais de mim
irei grande também acabei na califórnia
a dor é muito bonito mas ainda tinha
aquelas idéias na minha cabeça de que eu
toquei uma vida melhor pra mim mas parte
de criar uma vida melhor pra mim é criar
uma vida melhor para as outras pessoas
também
então com 19 anos e queria entender mais
a origem de mais o mundo viu que eu
peguei minha mochila
eu fui até pegando a gente falando
interior mesmo o inter onde a água não
tinha eletricidade o que se tinha água
de idade é um homem de sorte por diante
e eu passei três meses lá três vezes a
boiando
talvez pequenos como falava a língua
como é ensinado nas escolas lado e
começa a haver muitos problemas
muitos dos problemas que nós todos aqui
dentro na tv
queremos talvez na rua mas em algumas a
vivenciar mais de 500 sem pernas com
pólio se arrastando pela rua e uma
pessoa correndo na minha frente ea
família com quem amy não sofria de
malária e quando você vê a injustiça
quando você olha e princesa do ser
humano
a gente já passou um pouquinho que faz
ah você também vê a esperança
você também vê o sorriso sorriso de uma
criança você vê a possibilidade de
futuro e eu quando voltei pra faculdade
aqui são alguns dos colegas
ah eu queria fazer alguma coisa que eu
não queria ser apenas reclamar do
problema está lá é problema do governo
o problema de outra pessoa porque mundo
errado porque o mundo é injusto sim
talvez não consiga explicar isso mas é o
meu dever ser parte da solução porque
somos uma solução só parte do problema
então criou uma organização destaques da
faculdade para treinar mas nos colegas
como essas pessoas aqui e começar a
mandar eles no interior da índia para
eles poderem também a mesma vivência tem
a mesma experiência criativa e quem sabe
abrir a visão delas pra começar a pensar
por que é que eu posso fazer mais esse
mundo
ah e eu nunca tive essa idéia de que eu
ia fazer muito mais do que isso começou
a crescer igual ao tema de hoje é forma
de funcionar
eu comecei a tomar o número a um outro
número a número um desses anos
eu pensei olha eles estão fazendo o
projeto naquela região onde eu trabalhei
foi na minha comunidade ficou um pouco
um pouquinho de fundos
aí o seguinte eu pensei olha passado a
gente consegue uma biblioteca que está a
gente fazer outro projeto esse ano
aí seria mais um número que a gente
arrecada os pontos e construir um
laboratório de segundo grau na escola na
e mandando esse pessoal e no final a
faculdade rodada mais ou menos 50 a 60
pessoas aqui tal laboratório de grau que
está servindo à muitas meninas porque
quando você educa uma menina vai ficar
com a família toda a lançar um outro
projeto a eles não tinha um estilo uma
ambulância mas não estava funcionando
a gente não vamos ficar esperando
coberta consertar alguma outra pessoa
aposentar porque a gente não consegue um
pouquinho
falei com a comunidade
consegui as pessoas se interessarem por
essa visão
a gente conta com 11 mas aí a gente
precisa também de uma ambulância porque
tem muita gente que tem essa decisão eu
quero fazer alguma coisa pelo mundo tem
muita gente todos vocês que estão aqui
eu acho que pensam dessa forma mas a
dificuldade é que a gente não tem
necessariamente os meios e os recursos
ou a coragem de largar a nossa própria
vida e se dedicar à vida dos outros
eu apresento um outro modelo se você usa
os seus recursos através de parcerias se
você usa internet que é o jeito que eu
conseguir fazer isso eu usei o facebook
eu usei o twitter eu usei tudo o que eu
aprendi na minha vida em termos de
educação eu apliquei nesse projeto
se você usa tudo isso você consegue
somar um mais um bronze no vira 2,11
aqui o atendimento o hospital hoje
atende a mil pessoas por mês
a agente tenta muito pegar mães
somente as mães que estão tendo o
primeiro filho a ajudar vacinar ajudar
contra a malária ajudar contra a cólera
e eu queria resume um pouquinho eu
peguei uma frase aqui talvez se lembrem
navegar é preciso
eu naveguei esse projeto porque eu senti
dentro de mim que eu precisava fazer
isso não era alguma coisa que alguém
pediu pra mim não é alguma coisa que eu
precisava fazer para minha carreira mas
é alguma coisa que precisava fazer a
minha própria alma
a eutv 15 anos fazendo isso no projeto
de um dia mas a mensagem que queria
passar é que um projeto desses
você não precisa ser rico você não
precisa ser velho
só não precisa ser jovem você não
precisa ser nada o que você precisa é de
um compromisso é de um compromisso e de
uma tia de um de uma estratégia ea minha
estratégia foi essa a causa andei e a
não está aparecendo aqui completamente
mas a fazer parcerias
eu não tentei reinventar a roda eu
tentei conectar várias partes da roda
se vocês quiserem saber um pouco mais eu
resumiria aqui o website o facebook o
twitter
eu adoraria online no facebook se vocês
puderem a ajuda a gente fazer a levantar
mais fundos
o meu desafio atual é que o hospital não
precisa mais de mim é o último passo
nessa jornada
eu estou trabalhando pra que eu sei eu
fique aposentado do hospital porque uma
instituição tem que ser maior do que o
indivíduo essa é uma visão coletiva
não sou eu são várias pessoas e o
hospital tem que pertencer à comunidade
tem que ser gerido pela comunidade se
você está querendo fazer uma diferença
a comunidade tem que fazer a diferença
então o que eu tô trabalhando agora é
que o hospital não precisa mais de mim a
gente está incentivando mais e mais
pessoas a virem pagar uma quantia
pequena 10 30 reais a serem atendidos
e se eu consegui atingir
um pouquinho maior do que eu estou a
roda a máquina vai começar a funcionar o
hospital que não existia vai ficar de pé
ea minha visão próxima seria que quando
o hospital fica de pé
ele começa a correr e começa a
desencadear outros hospitais
outras escolas outros projetos não
projeto só meus mas quem sabe aqui de
outras pessoas que estão aqui eu queria
terminar aqui só com uma das frases que
mais admiro ele a queda marca admite ela
escreveu eu vou ler aqui nunca do grid
que um pequeno grupo de pessoas
conscientes e engajados possa mudar o
mundo
de fato é a única coisa que mudou quando
gadú